[Música]
ahora muy bienvenidos a 5 minutos con
comenzaron las audiencias por los
múltiples atentados yihadistas del 13 de
noviembre de 2015 en parís estamos
hablando de un mega juicio sin
precedentes es histórico y que busca
justicia para las víctimas de los
atentados simultáneos en el estadio de
francia una zona de cafés de parís y
también en la sala de conciertos
bataclán y saludamos ya mismo a la
politóloga francesa austin richard ella
es además experta en relaciones
internacionales
agustín richard muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en france 24 bueno en el
antiguo palacio de justicia de parís se
construyó una sala especial solo para
realizar estas audiencias con la
presencia de más de 300 abogados
periodistas familiares de víctimas
algunos afectados temen que la justicia
no se dará usted qué escenario prevé en
este juicio
bueno buenos días sin lugar a dudas este
juicio va a ser realmente muy importante
por su carácter histórico por su
carácter simbólico no olvidemos que la
sociedad francesa quedó muy traumatizado
estos múltiples atentados en el 2015 y
es la posibilidad para francia de hacer
justicia justamente 12 personas podrían
llevar cadena perpetua por lo que pasó
ya muchos están muertos sin lugar a duda
es la posibilidad para francia de
construir una memoria colectiva
alrededor de lo que pasó es la
posibilidad también de construir un
diálogo es la primera vez que víctimas y
victimarios se van a encontrar y es la
posibilidad para francia de salir de
pronto más unida que nunca de estos este
episodio que ocurrió hace siete años o
de pronto como usted lo dijo más
dividida que nunca porque no todo el
mundo está de acuerdo sobre las penas
que deberían incurrir estos terroristas
hablaba ustedes precisamente de la
necesidad de construir una memoria
colectiva
porque la importancia de sentar un
precedente en este juicio porque podría
durar como decíamos varios meses ayudar
a esto a francia a sanar esta herida
es importante que francia empiece a
construir un
diálogo sobre lo que es el terrorismo
que ha pasado
y de construir una reflexión alrededor
del islam y del lugar del islam de
manera general en francia no olvidemos
que cuando se va a cerrar este juicio es
decir en mayo de 2022 empezará la
carrera presidencial para para francia
así que es sin lugar a duda este juicio
va a tener un lugar importante dentro
del debate público en entrar el debate
político es muy importante que la
sociedad francesa
construya digamos una legitimidad un
consenso alrededor de la d
siempre
combatir el terrorismo pero aceptar que
el terrorismo no es igual a la práctica
de un islam moderado en francia y que
muchos apoyan el islam pero no el
terrorismo entonces es importante
realmente
deslegitimar
el terrorismo pero legitimar una
práctica del islam que sea un islam
moderado que no esté que sea un stand
republicano como le dice por ejemplo
emanuel marcó el 52 como cambio a
francia tras estos atentados hubo un
antes y un después en el país claro que
sí yo me acuerdo muy bien que este clima
de miedo no estamos acostumbrados a
vivirlo porque tras estos atentados no
es solamente unos cuerpos que fueron
atacados esto una simbólica es toda una
filosofía de vida esto una idea de
universalismo de laicismo que fue
atacado lo que se atacó realmente fue el
modo de vida de francia las mujeres que
salen las cafés la persona las personas
que toman alcohol que
libremente todo eso es lo que fue
atacado tras estos atentados así que la
sociedad francesa quedó muy traumatizado
porque empezó a vivir con miedo y eso
realmente es lo que querían los
terroristas entonces yo me acuerdo que
después en los días después varias
iniciativas nacieron como todos en el
café todos en el restaurante en gestos
de solidaridad con lo que pasó con las
víctimas pero también en la defensa de
un ideal con una filosofía de vida
diciendo no vamos a tener miedo no vamos
a dejarnos hacer eso es lo que somos eso
es nuestra esencia y lo tenemos que
defender y creo que el presidente de
manel manjón y consuelo en este entonces
han sido muy enfáticos en que francia no
va a renunciar a su filosofía y a su
ideal político de universalismo
esperemos que se haga justicia a ellos y
no lo hiciera muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en frenas 24 en nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
continuar informando se en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france24 punto
com
[Música]